herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live
vor zehn tagen hat russland eine neue
große offensive im osten der ukraine
gestartet doch wo stehen die russischen
truppen jetzt wie ist die lage heute das
russische militär meldete gestern die
einnahme von mehreren ukrainischen
dörfern und heute meldet der ukrainische
generalstab ganz frisch der feind
verstärkt seine offensive es gebe
angriffe praktisch in alle richtungen
und die russen hätten tatsächlich
geländegewinne gemacht es gibt wenig
belastbare ganz konkrete verifizierbare
informationen aus dem don bass direkt
von der frontlinie trotzdem wollen wir
versuchen uns ein bild der lage zu
machen zum einen sprechen wir mit dem
militär und sicherheitsexperten markus
kaim zuallererst wollen wir aber
sprechen mit meinem zdf kollegen unserem
reporter dara hassanzadeh daran ist
nämlich in mikro das ist eine
millionenstadt in der schon zehntausende
von menschen ukrainern aus dem osten der
ukraine geflüchtet sind und von nico ist
daran die frontlinie ganz nah an die
frontlinie gefahren und ist jetzt wieder
zurück in die prob daran was hast du auf
dieser fahrt erlebt wo seid ihr genau
hin gefahren welche eindrücke habt ihr
da bekommen ja
wir sind dort morgen um 6.30 von mikro
losgefahren und zwei den ob last haben
die stadt das ist die letzte front
frontstadt vor donets die hat 70.000
einwohner gehabt
und die lage dort sei so stabil gewesen
dass die fahrt zu verantworten war der
weg dorthin war anfänglich etwas
unwirklich die wirklich die sonne hat
geschienen weite felder des landes flach
und es war manchmal so dass man sich
gerade vor zu vorstellen können konnte
wie im sommer die sonnenblumenfelder
erwachsen und man die nationalflagge
quasi auf der die landschaft gezeichnet
sieht gelb und blau
dabei lehrt man sich immer mehr dem
heißen krieg der frontlinie wir haben
unterwegs das hilft mir natürlich nicht
film sehr viel militär gesehen wir haben
schwerer waffen gesehen wir haben am bug
systeme gesehen zur luftabwehr wir haben
auch
gepanzerte fahrzeuge gesehen und sehr
viele mannschaftswagen so dass das indiz
dass immer härtere kämpfer erwartet
werden durch diese beobachtungen schon
gedeckt sind
also das heißt ist die ukraine versuchen
immer mehr nachschub wenn du sagst ihr
habt ja sehr viele waffen gesehen
versuchen nachschub an die frontlinie zu
bringen
das war ganz deutlich
mehrere von raststätte zur raststätte
haben wir immer mehr soldaten getroffen
eine erstaunlich gelöste atmosphäre
als sie uns als presse sahen war niemand
nervös dass wir sie filmen konnten
unser kameramann hat auch einige
gespräche geführt
und wurde zum beispiel von einem
sag ich mal für
führungspersonal mitgeteilt ich kannte
den rang jetzt nicht genau dass sie
schon ein anderes problem haben nämlich
dass leute die checkpoints verlassen und
zwar nicht weil sie quasi desertieren
sondern im gegenteil sie wollen an die
front und das ist natürlich was die
organisation angeht für die ukrainische
armee ein problem denn die
übermotivation will ich es mal nennen
also in die stadt ankam hat sich ein
ganz anderes bild ergeben als war leer
sind nur noch 30 prozent der bevölkerung
der einwohner sind sind da oder man muss
sagen noch da sei erstaunlich viel denn
die front ist von dieser stadt wirklich
sichtbar sie ist am horizont 25
kilometer entfernt und dann das gelände
so flach ist kann man ja auch bis zum
horizont sehen dass ihr habt also gaben
am ende der bilder gesehen so einen boom
ran
noch ein paar garagen und dann war da
eben so eine baum linie zu sehen das ist
also wirklich die frontlinie und was
habt ihr da das ist genau erlebt er hat
dir dann was ich was artilleriefeuer da
gehört sind granaten über euch geflogen
oder was merkt man dort
nein wir haben was sie gleich angehen
gar nichts gehört das kann aber auch
sein dass in den stunden in denen wir da
waren vielleicht genau an dieser stelle
gar keine gefechte waren oder nicht in
der lautstärke oder der wind stand so
uns hat der polizeichef der stadt
erzählt dass er für die leute versucht
zu beruhigen die noch da sind und sagt
die raketen die ihr seht dass sie nicht
die gefährlichen die dir hört auch nicht
es weil die schlagen nicht hier ein und
wenn die explosionen kommen ist es zu
spät die menschen haben sich enorm
vorbereitet sie haben uns in ihre bunker
systeme geführt es ist ein streich
stufiges system erst mal gegen die
normalen luftangriffe aber dann haben
sie noch
einen inneren kreis an bunkern
gegründet in denen große mengen nahrung
wasser strom diesel vorräte lagen weil
sie sich auf eine ein kessel um
vorbereiten und der polizeichef selbst
stammt aus mario pohl er hat uns gezeigt
wie das haus sieht in dem sein
appartement war und sie sind bereit auch
diesen weg zu gehen die motivation
dieser menschen ist
wirklich nicht in frage zu stellen das
heißt also ich versteh dich richtig
daran dass selbst die bilder von mario
pohl dass die menschen dort in progress
wissen ja was in mariupol geschehen ist
führt nicht dazu dass die menschen also
zumindest alle menschen programms
verlassen haben ein verfliegen sondern
sich sogar auf eine umzingelung
einkesselung vorbereiten
also alle
menschen die wir die wollten sind schon
lange evakuiert auch die sozialstationen
sind
bedürftige sind evakuiert aber alle
menschen die bleiben wollen dürfen auch
bleiben und das sind so sagte uns die
beigeordnete des bürgermeisters ungefähr
30 prozent und für diese 30 prozent
haben sie alle vorkehrungen getroffen
sie selber wollen einfach ihre stadt
nicht aufgeben und einen weiteren
vormarsch weiter
verhindern und falls sie eingenommen
wird dann möglichst lange auch als
eingeschlossene stadt truppen binden um
kämpfe zu machen auf dem weg wenn ich
das noch mal nachfragen darf in die
stadt haben wir auch viele
schützengräben gesehen die einfach so in
felder gezogen werden um weitere
verteidigungslinien für einen rückzug
schon vorbereitet zu haben so dass der
vormarsch der russischen armee auf
keinen fall nur so funktioniert das
einmal die front durchbrochen wird und
dann wäre quasi kein widerstand zu
erwarten bis zum beispiel der
nächstgrößeren stadt es ist auf einen
langen kampf ausgerichtet was wir sehen
konnten da schließe ich meine frage an
sarah du hast ja mit vielen menschen
gesprochen und den wird wahrscheinlich
auch nicht ganz entgangen sein dass in
berlin heute eine wichtige entscheidung
gefallen ist der bundestag hat
abgestimmt mit großer mehrheit ist es
ein jahr geworden gibt es grünes licht
für jetzt die lieferung schwerer waffen
an die ukraine eben auch luftabwehr
panzer was sagen denn die menschen in
programms zum beispiel dazu dass es
diese lieferungen jetzt gibt
achselzuckend wurde das zur kenntnis
genommen dort es ist auch relativ frisch
gewesen bis dass zu den normalen
menschen durchgedrungen ist es ist auch
nicht ihre größte sorge im moment wenn
man so nah an der front ist weil ja auch
sie wissen dass von dem versprechen
eines panzers noch sehr lange dauert bis
er wirklich bei ihnen zb ankäme es ist
er aber der rückkehr so dass das ein
thema ist aber sie haben so lange
gebeten und so früh gewarnt dass sie das
bestimmt also die stimmung ist er so sie
nehmen es wohlwollend zur kenntnis aber
es ist der bittere beigeschmack
dabei dass man solange flehen musste und
vor allem sie sind noch lange nicht hier
die versprochenen panzer wie ist denn
dein eindruck kann es sein dass dann
diese schweren waffen wenn sie denn
jetzt erst geliefert werden sollen wenn
sie jetzt erst auf den weg geschickt
werden zu spät kommen
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen weil
diese die ukrainische armee hat ihre
fähigsten truppen in der ost ukraine
eingesetzt die sie haben ja auch bisher
bewiesen dass sie gut agieren können und
sie haben auch bei kiew bei der
offensive auch gelände verluste in kauf
zu nehmen um trotzdem noch schlagkräftig
zu sein ich
rechne nicht damit dass es
einen schnellen sturz gibt auf
eine seite
jetzt hat russland gestern gesagt man
habe viele militärische ziele in der
ukraine aus der luft angegriffen und es
wurde gestern in agenturen in meldungen
aus moskau immer wieder betont man habe
viele waffen aus dem westen zerstört wie
sieht das denn aus bombardiert jetzt die
russische luftwaffe auf einmal
eisenbahnlinien straßen etc um eben
nachschub aus dem westen von deutschland
anderen ländern eben zu unterbinden ist
schon sehr auffallend dass
mit dem mit der planung kann man ja
schon fast sagen der der offensive im
osten dann auch langsam aber immer mehr
infrastruktur ziele
bombardiert wurden speziell
güterbahnhöfe brücken eisenbahnbrücken
eine ganz entscheidende richtung
rumänien und sie haben schon vor jetzt
ganz gezielt diese nachschublinien zu
unterbinden das macht im übrigen auch
sinn wenn jetzt keine neuen
waffenlieferungen
versprochen worden werden weil es eine
sehr sehr lange front ist die aus
schützengräben von artillerie und panzer
betrieb geführt wird da braucht man viel
munition man braucht auch eine gute
logistik auch was verletzte angeht wir
haben zum beispiel eigentlich eine
zusage gehabt morgen im
militärkrankenhaus von chapeau richards
zu drehen das wurde uns heute aber um
verständnis bitten abgesagt weil doch
die kämpfe zugenommen haben und die zahl
der verwundeten so hoch ist dass
medienleute einfach den betrieb stören
würden also diese logistik ist ein ganz
zentraler punkt und das weiß auch die
russische seite wenn ich das aber doch
sagen darf die logistik ist natürlich
auch für die russische armee von
entscheidender bedeutung und das war in
dem krieg bisher nicht die stärke der
russen
da jetzt fragen wir in der zwischenzeit
viele user wo du dich genau befindet und
wo du genau berichtet vielleicht müssen
wir einmal noch mal sagen du bist jetzt
in die
profile flüchtende schon angekommen sind
und du bist nach puck aufs gefahren
vielleicht kannst du noch mal ganz genau
einen autokauf so vielleicht ganz so
noch mal ganz genau 1 auch in welche
rolle spielt ist und welche rolle eben
dieser und wo genau der kleine ort ist
also wipro war schon zu sowjetzeiten
eine industriezentrum für vor allem für
stahlindustrie und auch
rüstungsindustrie war hier angesiedelt
von hier der fließt der mächtige fluss
ins schwarze meer und da wird der stahl
auch exportiert wie der weizen kann er
jetzt ja nicht mehr über das mehr
exportiert werden wegen der seeblockade
der häfen
durch die russen
von hier sind wir eigentlich ziemlich
exakt gen osten nach donets gefahren die
kreisstadt
prokop liegt ungefähr 50 kilometer
luftlinie von der stadt donezk
entfernt und ist teil des ob last also
der region donets die aber in dem teil
den die ukraine zeit 2014 zurückgewinnen
konnten vor den separatisten und dort
sind natürlich auch sehr
kriegs erfahrene menschen weil zeit 2014
ist dort der krieg nicht erst seit der
offensive vor zehn tagen
und das ist einfach der punkt man muss
sich nur mal vor augen führen dass
dieser konflikt ja seit längerem besteht
und wir erinnern uns noch mal bevor der
krieg jetzt angefangen hat am 24 februar
diese kriegserklärung von putin war er
hat putin ja zwei tage zuvor erklärt
dass man diese unabhängigkeit die
souveränität der regionen bonn jetzt und
lohans anerkennt und danach ist es
letzten endes dann jetzt zum ausbruch zu
diesem angriffskrieg gekommen deshalb
jetzt die frage
russland putin hat ja nun davon
abgelassen oder eingesehen dass er das
ziel nicht erreichte kiew zu umzingeln
kiew die hauptstadt der ukraine
einzunehmen ist es jetzt so dass dieses
dass dieser kampf jetzt im osten der
versuch den don was komplett eben unter
kontrolle zu kriegen dass das so eine
art minimalziel ist was putin vor dem 9
mai erreichen will wenn in moskau das
ende des zweiten weltkriegs gefeiert
wird und ist das deshalb jetzt so eine
art ja entscheidungsschlacht
also die schlacht kann meiner meinung
nach schon sehr entscheidend werden wenn
es zb den russischen truppen gelänge die
ukrainische armee genau in dem gebiet wo
wir waren
einzukesseln indem sie vom süden und von
rajiv aus dem norden einen ring schließt
und so mit denen die versorgung den
nachschub
abschneidet
andererseits wird für ihn auch die
stadtkassen extrem wichtig sein um die
landbrücke zur krim zu sichern und
carson ist wiederum auch ein einfallstor
richtung odessa und im endeffekt in die
ganze küste und die ganzen helfen wenn
ich kenne jetzt seine ziele nicht aber
ich könnte mir vorstellen er wird
militärisch alles versuchen was er als
dies zu erreichen um die ukraine vom
meer abzuschneiden weil dann hat sie was
den export von agrargütern angeht ein
riesenproblem wirtschaftlich weiter zu
existieren
insofern trifft wahrscheinlich zu dass
es doch entscheidende tage sind wie
manche beobachter eben sagen da recht
herzlichen dank für diese eindrücke für
die schilderungen für diese hintergründe
direkt aus nicole gar nicht mal so weit
weg von der frontlinie wo du eben heute
war es vielen vielen dank daran mach's
gut
ja wie gesagt vor zehn tagen da begann
die große neue offensive der russischen
truppen im osten der ukraine wenn wir
genau dorthin schauen und die letzten
tage verstreichen lassen noch mal im
zeitraffer in den nordosten der ukraine
schauen rechts oben dann erkennt man wie
putins truppen stück für stück
vorankommen allerdings recht langsam das
wird hier auch deutlich
wir reden jetzt über die lage dort mit
dem militär und sicherheit experten
markus kaim von der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik herr kaim wie
schätzen sie die lage derzeit ein im
osten der ukraine
also wichtigsten punkte und sie gemacht
es gibt fortschritte und die sind
unabweisbar die kann man auf der karte
nachzeichnen aber sind weit von dem
entfernt aus russland aussicht gestellt
hat und dass russland vielleicht von
sich selber erwartet von den russischen
streitkräften nach der enttäuschung der
ersten kriegswochen auch die haben sie
angesprochen dass russland nicht in der
lage gewesen gewesen ist die oder das
russische militär nicht nur lage gewesen
die ersten krieg siedlungen zu setzen
eine politische enthauptet die ukraine
durchzusetzen
eine besetzung der hauptstadt kiew die
einsetzung einer weise an regierung das
war sozusagen die ziele am 24 februar
davon ist wenig übriggeblieben nicht zu
sagen gar nicht mehr absolut mit ihrer
these überein das ist die rückfahrt
position der plan d d plan b lautet
mario pohl zu besetzen als brücke
zwischen donders der krim um das erlaube
einen brückenkopf zu steigernde land
brücke zu schlagen zwischen diesen
beiden gebieten die dann die ukraine vom
also mehr ableger wurde und der zweite
fokus ist in anführungsstrichen
endgültige befragten der beiden
abtrünnigen volksrepublik in ihrem
verwaltungs bezogen wie die ukraine sie
feste aber darüber hinaus sind die szene
fix fortschritte bleiben außer sprossen
oder sich enttäuscht und ich bitte nicht
vergessen zu werden eigentlich ist der
kriegsverlauf russland nicht nur
enttäuschen sondern nahezu einer
niederlage weil von den selbst
gestellten kriegt sie hinten wenig
erreicht worden und wenn jetzt nur die
karten schauen da könnte man das
argument machen und sagen
diese beiden volksrepublik hat russland
politisch bereits von folien 24v
kontrolliert und die sind bereits vor
dem 24 februar an wirksamer hebel auch
die politische entwicklung der ukraine
gewesen dafür einen krieg das ist ein
kalkül was man kaum jemand weg
jetzt ist es so der ukrainische
generalstab teilte eben heute mit es
werde an fast allen fronten geschossen
besonders unter beschuss sein logo
hanske und dann jetzt und in issum seien
weitere truppen zusammengezogen worden
und dort wollen wir uns das ganze mal
genauer anschauen
aktuell im zentrum des russischen
angriffskriegs der osten die region nahe
der kleinen stadt verschanzt dort nehmen
putins truppen eine strategisch wichtige
front straße ins visier die zwischen
ragt der zweitgrößten stadt der ukraine
und dem russisch besetzte nie so ganz in
der nähe die man dort griffen putin
soldaten auch eine eisenbahn miran vor
dem beschuss fliehen immer mehr menschen
und auch vor den kämpfen die sich
ausweiten ganz im osten der ukraine
wenn wir uns das kurze information stück
angeschaut haben zwei strategische frage
an den militärexperten
ist das wirklich jetzt so dass russland
versucht auch strategische ziele also
straßen nachschublinien zu kappen
sozusagen für die ukraine
beziehungsweise das liest man auch immer
wieder
sozusagen ukrainische truppen
einzukesseln also mit einer
scherenbewegung von nord und süd dann
letzten endes die starken ukrainischen
verbände einzukesseln
also die russischen streitkräfte am seit
dem pianisten februar eine tradition
ihre infrastruktur der ukraine unter
beschuss genommen um die ukraine als
land nicht mehr lebenswert zu machen und
damit auch fluchtbewegung
lebensmittellager
treibstofflager krankenhäuser vieles
andere mehr mit einer ausnahme die
infrastruktur kann tatsächlich das habe
ich völlig zurecht angesprochen die
eisenbahn war davon ausgenommen
vornehmen mit
aus der überlegung heraus dass die sd1
man ihn für einen russischen firma
klopfen von nutzen sein kann oder hätten
von nutzen sein können und da ist
irgendwie doch eine andere entwicklung
in diese richtung dass sie uns jetzt
darum gehen das sagen das argument
umzudrehen den vormarsch der ukrainische
truppen oder die versorgung die
logistische versorgung der ukrainischen
aufzuhalten zu unterbrechen und für
diesen zweck werden dann eben auch die
entsprechenden infrastruktur
verbindungen von eisenbahn problem hin
zu chancen und das ist denn sowohl ein
paradigmenwechsel aber doch eine andere
art 6-führung
erkennbar ist und zum zweiten punkt dass
ich absolut genauso das ist irgendwie
der versuch teile der ukrainischen armee
einzukesseln und auch das ist ja alles
angesprochen wollte es sind vielleicht
nicht im technischen sinne elite
ausbildete ausgebildete truppe aber sind
die erfahrensten druck weil diese den
sie 2014 in einen permanenten krieg wir
denken immer dann zu einer 24 februar
wenig ausgemacht 1 ausglich 2040 ende
und diese kann verfahren truppen die
zahl an der demarkationslinie stehen sie
sollen aus dem kampf genommen werden und
vor diesem hintergrund ist das russisch
schaden sie nachvollziehbar
jetzt haben wir fragen von unseren usern
busch briegel schreibt über youtube wie
sieht die lage denn hinter den
russischen linien auf ukrainischem
territorium aus gibt es hier berichte
über widerstand oder unterdrückung die
halbwegs verlässlich sind erreicht sie
da etwas in der richtung
also was erkennbar ist dass versucht
wird von russischer seite sozusagen eine
art zivile verwaltung zu installieren
das ist erkennbar immobilia sein wo ist
zumindest gerüchte gibt die sind
unterschiedlich das dass dort eine art
referendum gehen soll es sollte eine
weitere autonome volksrepublik
ausgerufen werden soll und das ergebnis
des referendums schultes an gelenken und
es ist das bemühen die in rubel als
zahlungsmittel einzuführen also wenn sie
so wollen eine gewisse normalität in
russischen augen durchzuführen und vor
allem
die rahmenbedingungen dafür zu schaffen
für eine positiv formuliert ganz enge
anbindung dieser besetzten gebieten
russland ich vermeide jetzt den beruf
aktion und dafür gibt es gerne in die
indizien dass diese gebiete dann
tatsächlich zu russland geschlagen wird
jetzt sollen sie politisch
wirtschaftlich infrastrukturell sehr eng
an ostern angeboten werden wie wir da
ist ja beim don bastian sehen musste mit
einem beispiel zu sagen was in den
letzten jahren an die ukraine schlüpfen
600.000 russische pässe ausgegeben
worden damit schafft man fakten und das
ist eine weitere illustration auch das
würde mich nicht wundern wenn das in
absehbarer zeit in diesen besetzten
gebieten passieren würde sozusagen das
ist für die ukraine schwieriger
sozusagen das sind unsere gebiete und
seriöse seiten immer leicht zu sagen wir
im rings fakten geschaffen jenigen die
gehen soll sind geflohen oder sind
vertrieben worden und netzt ich würde es
dann zu einer art informieren
sie haben es selber schon angesprochen
auf der einen seite ist jetzt das ja sie
haben es formuliert das reduzierte
minimalziel offenbar nach dem es eben
mit der einnahme kiew nicht geklappt hat
der kompletten unterwerfung der
kompletten ukraine erinnerungsjahr
vierundzwanzigster februar was putin
alles gesagt hat anziehen
entnazifizierung bedeutet ja eigentlich
das wegfegen der regierung in kiew und
die sitzt doch deutlich im sattel jetzt
angesagt minimalziel
kontrolle über den don was sie haben sie
aber auch gesagt eben diesen streifen
als ausschuss mehr von der krim bis
russland mario pohl eben einzunehmen
persson westlich der krim ist ja schon
in russischer hand und was dort auch
noch weiter passiert mit mario pohl
ebenfalls östlich davon da schauen wir
uns ganz kurz an und reden darüber auch
im südosten von personen aus greift
russland richtung westen an im ziel die
500.000 einwohner stadt nikolaev die
absicht wohl den ukrainischen zugang zum
meer bald komplett zu kappen unter
beschuss außerdem erneut mario pohl vor
allem das gigantische stahlwerk in dem
das ukrainische asaf regiment
eingeschlossen ist nun ein hilferuf des
vize kommandeurs
bei uns sind mehr als 500 menschen mit
unterschiedlich schweren verletzungen
das problem ist sie können sie nicht
versorgen sie nicht chirurgisch
behandeln
sein appell helft uns vor allem den mit
uns eingeschlossenen zivilisten und den
verwundeten
sie haben es eben schon gesagt im grunde
damen wenigstens ein strategisches ziel
scheint im moment zu funktionieren von
der krim nach osten her bis russland die
ukraine vom aktionär abzuschneiden was
bitter ist droht das ganze denn auch im
westen also odessa ist noch nicht
umzingelt nichts dergleichen aber
bewirkt dass auch die gefahr der
russischen truppen von herr sonnen
daneben weiter richtung westen
marschieren
also sie sagen es wirklich richtig es
gibt zumindest keine indizien dafür bei
syrien russische kriegslogik passen weil
es geht hier letztlich nicht mehr darum
ukrainisches territorium zu behalten
aber es geht nach die forderung die
ukraine politik zu dominieren also es
geht weniger um die errichtung eines
imperiums die richtung von hegemonie
politische vorherrschaft wurde aus
ukraine klar formuliert und politische
gefolgschaft und um diese
sicherzustellen muss man den gegner
schwächen in abhängigkeit verfestigen
und diesen zweck natürlich eben auch die
abriegelung von schwarzen meer
beziehungsweise also auch schon mehr
weil man damit die handelsbeziehungen
wie wir das wirklich idee mit der op
nicht sprechen würde und würde sie
zusagen vom internationalen handel
abkoppeln man kann andere wege gehen das
wird jetzt versucht
nur pohl rauszubekommen das kann man
versuchen in rumänien aber es ist lässt
sich kein ersatz für das für den zugang
für den ukrainer hätten und ich wäre
nicht ganz verwundert wenn die russische
seite schon darüber nachdenkt angesichts
des ausland erfolge über eine form von
ich sage jetzt nicht friedensregelung
aber einer politischen regelung wieder
geht zu ende gehen würde und da geht es
ja darum maximale gewinne zu erzielen
teltow realen sinne um gegebenenfalls
ein komponist zu machen der dann auch
vor den eigenen wählern werden und wären
dann bestand haben also anders wenn wir
tatsächlich in wenigen wochen ich fand
sie jetzt mal eine friedenskonferenz
unter der schirmherrschaft der osze oder
unter schirmherrschaft der beiden
nationen sehen würden dann wäre es
natürlich ein gewaltiges von mit dem
ostern buchen könnte und sagt ja wir
haben die ukraine bis april und wird
real ist die frage längst beantwortet
dann wird sowas garnicht gegebenenfalls
politisch diskutiert werden und damit
verschafft sich russland einen
erheblichen strategischen vorteil also
nicht nur operativen sinne auch im
politischen sinne das heißt die
militärischen schritte sind natürlich zu
sehen mit potenziellen
friedensverhandlungen und den gleichen
blick in die zukunft den sie gerade
machen das spekulieren was könnte dann
diskutiert werden verhandelt werden
macht auch user century 737 er fragt
russland setzt seit über zehn jahren
sehr militär für territoriale interessen
ein sollte man wieder einen frieden mit
gebiets verlusten der ukraine erkaufen
oder die grenze von 4 2 auf die grenzen
von vor 2014 bestehen geht in ihre
richtung
das ist eine ganz zentrale frage
und wo ja auch die
keine einigkeit einer der nato und
erinnert des westens gibt zum teil wird
diese frage was die eigentliche
kriegsziel sind ja gar nicht offen
ausgesprochen
deutschland um nur ein beispiel zu
bleiben das ist ein haben eine tradition
vornehme das vieh zu diskutieren was wir
wollen oder was sie nicht wiewohl also
beispiele wären die frage von
waffenlieferungen oder nicht schaffen
niveau ich frage einer flugverbotszone
über nicht so gut aber die frage ob das
sinnvoll ist kann man ja eigentlich nur
wenn man angehen kann was das politische
ziel ist was mit diesem lied maßnahmen
erreicht werden soll und in der tat da
sind die beispiel die miete ihrer nutzer
angegeben hat völlig recht nicht es gibt
für mich keinen erkennbaren konsens im
westen unter den westlichen hauptstädten
ob man sagt das politische ziel ist eine
wiederherstellung des status quo vom
februar vom 23 februar 2022 ohne geht
der geht die ambition weiter wollen wir
tatsächlich in status quo von 2014
erreichen also die ukraine befähigen die
krim zurückzuerobern in donners komplett
zurück zu erobern ist unser ziel so
fantastisch das klingen mag in einem
reflex in moskau auszulösen oder und das
ist nicht so fantastisch das was dem was
die amerikanische regierung im letzten
tagen angekündigt hatte sie wolle jetzt
dazu übergehen russland zu sprechen was
dann übersetzen kann amerikaner das ziel
ist es die amerikaner sind nun mal die
führungsmacht des westens jedes oder so
vielen russisches militär gerät in der
ukraine kaputt zu schließen wie es
irgend geht um die russland mini tiere
so zu schwächen dass eine zweite angriff
auf die ukraine dann nicht auf die
ukraine erfolgen würde sondern auch
voltaren auf georgien oder anderenorts
auf das baltikum unmöglich würde und da
hätte ich zumindest fragen ob die
bundesregierung dieses ziel teilt und
das will ich gar nicht bewerten sondern
das illustriert und mein punkt wir
diskutieren sehr gern aber das wie aber
das was damit erreicht werden soll
naturvision dunkel
ich will gleich zwei sachen aufnehmen
über beiden müssen wir reden weil er
sich heute geäußert hat kommen wir
gleich drauf aber sie haben es ja auch
gerade angesprochen transnistrien also
wenn wir richtung republik moldau
schauen und da gibt es eben ja auch
transnistrien das den konflikt oder das
problem da schreibt hier glied mafia
über youtube wie wahrscheinlich ist der
einmarsch in die west ukraine auch über
transnistrien und
andrea michael feuerstein schreibt über
youtube welche bedeutung hat
transnistrien für den weiteren
kriegsverlauf im süden und osten
also das erste kann ich nicht beurteilen
das wäre wirklich in die kristallkugel
zu schauen und ich bin da genauso ratlos
überhaupt genau dieselben informationen
vorlegen wie sie ja auch es hat diese
brombach und pflegen das nächste rennen
gegeben explosion uns noch neutraler zu
sagen deren hintergrund bin ich richtig
einschätzen können das hat die region
oder land weiter nicht stabilisiert
transnistrien moldawien
wobei transnistrien gar nicht so
abtrünnig ist von moldawien wie das
gemeint sind berichtet wurde die
transnistrien und breitenthal
moldawische pässe
weil es ihnen den handel mit der
europäischen union erlaubt
sind sie westlich orientiert aber
tatsächlich nicht bleibt ihr befund klar
transnistrien hat eine militärbasis der
russischen seite also unter veränderten
vorzeichen
betrachtet russland transnistrien als
außenposten des russischen imperiums ihr
passt ja ausdrücklich unterbreiten wie
weit das ausgefüllte und überall das
weiter entwickelt wurde ist aus heutiger
sicht kann ich bin kreativ und genau so
spekulativ ist die frage ob das nist
tränen oder sogar mal dagegen das
nächste opfer der russischen expansion
wäre ich wäre aber das ist eine
momentaufnahme bisschen zurückhalten
wenn das alles stimmt dass sie ihnen
diskutiert haben die scheidende
ist die bescheidene erfolglose
streitkräfte wie demoralisierenden
wirkung auf die russischen streitkräfte
dann sollte man sich vielleicht mal
überlegen die nächsten krieg vom zaun zu
brechen also wie ihr volker sprechen ist
dass das will ich nicht wirklich
einleuchten aber man kann das ganze
projekt
von angriffskriegen auf die ukraine hat
wenig eingebracht und dennoch passiert
frage eben auch wo die logik ist
insofern fällt es dann eben auch schwer
das ganze zu verstehen kommen wir aber
eben auf die usa sie haben eben die usa
die beiden schon angeschnitten beiden
hat heute gesprochen er will die ukraine
hilfe deutlich aufstocken und er hat
gesagt er bittet den kongress um die
freigabe von 33 milliarden dollar 20
milliarden für waffen für munition 8,5
milliarden dollar für wirtschaftshilfe
und weitere drei milliarden dollar
sollen in humanitäre hilfe und
lebensmittelhilfe fliegen fließen und
das hat beiden heute gesagt
ich habe einen kongress einen antrag auf
wenige sicherheitspolitische
wirtschaftliche und humanitäre hilfe
gestellt damit helfen wir der ukraine
sich weiter gegen putins aggression zu
wehren so einem entscheidenden zeitpunkt
wir brauchen diese summe für die ukraine
kampf für die freiheit und
biden hat noch hinzugefügt die kosten
für diesen kampf 30 milliarden ist ja
eine ganze summe die kosten für diesen
kampf sind nicht billig aber die adresse
der aggression nachgeben wird mehr
kosten sagt biden hat er da recht
ja ich glaube er hat recht und das setzt
damit ihr eine bemerkenswerte
immer sagenweg änderung oder veränderte
prioritätensetzung der eigene
außenpolitik vor wenigen monaten haben
wir nach die usa aufgrund der
ankündigung des amerikanischen
präsidenten hätten nur noch ein einziges
interesse eine magnetische priorität im
indopazifik übersetzt die
auseinandersetzung china nichts anderes
und das hat der amerikanische präsident
auch deutlich gemacht erst war der grund
weshalb die usa aus afghanistan
abgezogen sind das hatte keine prämie
gewährt deuten immer wir wittmund china
china china und noch vor wenigen wochen
haben wir hier in berlin diskutiert wie
viel politische mit ihre finanzielle
aufmerksamkeit für europa überhaupt noch
bliebe und aufgrund des krieges ist
diese sorge
geschmolzen wie butter in der sonne ganz
das gegenteil also ist passiert das ist
eine verkehrung der premier die usa
haben seit dem 24
11.000 soldaten nach europa verlegt
osteuropäischen staaten der nato also an
die grenze möglichst nah zu ostern dann
die ganze ukraine
am gewaltige summen in die hand genommen
sehen die zahlen genannt 33 milliarden
dollar lassen zeit eines knappen budgets
eines ohnehin aufgrund von gebiet und
der wirtschaftskrise strapaziert bläst
das zeigt doch dass die usa kraftvoll
sich wieder als europäische sicherheits
macht präsentieren und was er sehen ist
das für viele leute überhaupt noch
einmal die rolle den usa als
sicherheitsgarant oder in europa
deutlich geworden ist auch fragen von
nuklearpolitik mit berger schutzschirm
oder so ähnlich wie in den letzten
monaten oder letzten jahren ja
eigentlich gar nicht mehr diskutieren
mussten sind jetzt wieder auf der
tagesordnung und wenn man verkürzt aber
dennoch nicht versagen darf das sagen
dann ist die nato die gewinnerin weg
diese unter führung der usa sozusagen
aber auch den westen an sich die sich
wiederfindet und
das sind das sind die usa kraft tor
zurückgekehrt
willkommen zur letzten frage es gibt
noch einen kommentar von andrea keil
slavik über youtube putin will alles
außer verhandlungen zudem hat er schon
wieder gedroht wo soll das enden
ja wo soll das enden
ich weiß auch schon die antwort auf
meine frage die haben sie schon nämlich
gegeben sie haben gesagt wir haben ja
leider keine kristallkugel aber unser
zdf-reporter mein kollege daran hat mir
erzählt er hat mit den ukrainern
gesprochen und ich habe ihn gefragt ja
wie ist denn die moral wie ist die
hoffnung wie sind sie denn wie sehen sie
das ganze und er sagte zu mir die sind
verdammt realistisch die haben
hoffnungen klar die moral ist groß aber
sie sind auch verdammt realistisch sie
wissen zitat daran dass es einer großen
stärke bedarf das ist unwahrscheinlich
hohe verluste auf russischer seite geben
kann dass russland an den
verhandlungstisch gezwungen wird das
also verluste oder eine niederlage so
groß ist dass die verhandlungen
vielversprechender sind als einfach
weiter zu kämpfen und dass diese große
stärke um putin zu verhandlungen zu
zwingen der das sagt andrea thal slavica
eben alles nicht will also keine
verhandlungen das ist die einschätzung
der ukraine wie sehen sie das wann wird
es frieden geben und wie kann dieser
moment erreicht werden also letztlich
ich weiß es auch nicht aber letztlich in
der regisseur zwei szenarien das erste
szenario wäre die kriegsparteien oder
die eine kriegspartei ring die anderen
nieder da denken wir vor allem an die
russische übermacht die ukraine liebe
ring wurde danach sieht es im moment
zumindest nicht so aus dass wir mögen
und sechs monaten an astoria dass die
ukraine wirklich nieder und politisch
militärisch das sehe ich im moment nicht
und die umgekehrte perspektive passt ja
ohnehin nicht die ukraine will sich
während geschützt wie die russische
seite die wäre das zweite szenario wäre
eine
ermüdung oder erschöpfung der
kriegspartei dass der die kosten so hoch
sind ihr preis so
der nutzen so gering dass letztlich
nichts mehr das nicht so vorangeht das
würde man daran sehen dass sich die
front nur noch marginal www dass die
schusswechsel abebben die es gibt eine
schießerei artilleriebeschuss aber nur
punktuell dann würden wir wieder
abflauen aber letztlich steht die frau
und so traurig die situation ist dass er
eigentlich der moment um wieder
politische initiativen spiel zu bringen
wir beide konflikt dass ein so erschöpft
sind und ihr kalkül ihr kosten nutzen
kalkül beginn zu verändern das wäre die
initiative zeit punkt für eine
politische initiative von wem auch immer
die komba und deutschland von der
europäischen union oder von den
vereinten nationen vor dem hintergrund
würde ich auch nicht so kritisch oder
bin ich nicht so kritisch ins gericht
gegangen mit dem generalsekretär der
gestern in moskau war natürlich hat er
nicht erreicht hat nichts mitgebracht
aber die vereinten nationen in
erinnerung rufen und vielleicht wir
sehen das in sechs wochen oder in acht
wochen oder in zwölf wochen wer weiß das
schon die vereinten nationen den
politischen rahmen um für für die
ukraine und die kostenseite in
verhandlungen einzutreten das ist so
heutige sich spekulativ aber das ist
vielleicht etwas worauf die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer achten
sollten in die frauen sich nicht mehr
bewegt damit sicheres indiz für eine
müde und das ist dann sagen kann er
spricht wieder die diplomatie im moment
überhaupt keine chance
also insofern sie haben recht wir haben
nicht die kristallkugel die wird uns
nicht die antwort geben aber wir werden
genau das tun was wir können sagen wir
werden in den nächsten wochen das ganze
beobachten und eben schauen was in sechs
sieben acht wochen ist und vielleicht
kommt es zu dem was sie beschrieben
haben ganz ganz herzlichen dank auf
jeden fall für ihre analyse antworten
für die hintergründe und erklärungen
vielen vielen dank an schönen abend noch
und danken
ja und danke auch an sie liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer für ihr
interesse das war der versuch die lage
im osten der ukraine überhaupt im
ukraine krieg zu sondieren einerseits
mit der us-seite unserem reporter vor
ort der heute nah an die frontlinie
gereist und markus kaim vielen dank für
ihr interesse an schönen abend noch
tschüss und auf wiedersehen